alright hi everyone and thank you so
much for having me here today I'm really
excited it's been great and this year
getting to know getting to know bill
getting to know others and I direct the
food law and policy clinic at Harvard
Law School and as part of our work this
year we've also been organizing the
deans food system challenge at the
Harvard Innovation Lab which is
sponsored by the Dean of the law school
Martha Minow and also deed Frank from
the school of public health so I know
there was a slide earlier about that but
it's really putting a challenge out to
the University to figure out with all
these smart minds here among our
students can we come up with innovations
that would make the food system
healthier more sustainable and more
equitable and so I'd like to start
actually just I love getting in front of
a group of non-lawyers because it's a
really great chance to educate people
about about what lawyers are and are not
and and kind of put a different spin on
I think what a lot of people expect and
so I think just wanted to explain what a
clinic is in the law school sense and
then also briefly about what what as
lawyers we have to bring to the table in
the food space and so a clinic in a law
school sent it's sort of like a clinic
in medical school or something like that
but the idea is that we're getting
students it's an action learning program
for students so we have both a
service-oriented mission that's outward
facing we work on projects we work on a
range of issues in the food system on
increasing access on improving
opportunities for small scale
unsustainable growers to participate in
the food system but we're also educating
law students and we're helping them both
get involved get the skills to be
involved in the food system but also
their learning transferrable skills
about just being creative problem
solvers and I think the other thing to
say about being a lawyer in this space
is that not all lawyers go to court and
sue people which is probably like the
most for the image of lawyers that most
people think of the way that we work
actually we don't litigate at all we use
our legal skills to help empower
communities and individuals and and
partners from other disciplines so that
they understand this field and then also
to change policy and figure out where is
the
all that's making this happen at the
other thing I wanted to say is that this
field is really growing in law schools I
think Harvard is at the forefront so
you'll hear later today from my
colleague Jake Carson who directs the
food law lab at Harvard Law School we're
doing great it's been incredibly
exciting but I in separate research I
did over the past few years with a
friend of mine we were looking at the
growth of this field across law schools
and saw that at the top hundred law
schools in the u.s. at that time this is
two year old data 20 law schools had now
food law and policy courses that are
pretty new i mean this is in the past
five years or so so it's exciting to be
in this space it's exciting to see it
grow it's another interest of mine and
our clinic has four major areas that we
work in one is really empowering Food
Policy councils and citizen groups that
are trying to take control of their food
system we also work on increasing food
access very consumer oriented and health
oriented work and on sustainable food
production which includes both
incentivizing people using better
practices and also trying to figure out
how we can change practices that might
be more harmful to the environment or
labor or animal welfare and but I'm
going to talk briefly as one case study
on our work around the issue of food
waste so this is an incredibly important
issue I think growing in terms of the
amount of people looking at it and
interested there's actually a New York a
couple of New York Times articles in the
past two days on this topic just how
this issue is really impacting the
United States and and the global the
global food system in the u.s. we waste
about forty percent of the food that we
produce so if you look at this chart
that forty percent of food that we end
up throwing away is makes up twenty five
percent of water use four percent of oil
use tons of pesticides and fertilizers
and other agricultural inputs and then
it goes to landfills where it makes up
more than fifteen percent of methane
emissions which is a really potent
greenhouse gas so this is a huge problem
aside from the environmental side of it
we're also living in this country right
now nearly fifteen percent of Americans
are food insecure meaning that they
don't have access at all times to it for
two
food for a healthy active life so this
is a really big issue and we've been
working on this particularly in the
legal setting and so we published a
report a year ago that was really
looking at expiration dates as one piece
of this puzzle many groups governments
intergovernmental agencies the UN the
natural resources defense council who is
our partner on this report had said
expiration dates are seemed to be a
problem someone should figure out what
they mean and why they're leading to so
much waste so we took this challenge on
and and and i just want to show you a
little bit of what this looks like to do
research in a legal context so we
started at the federal level and what we
found which may not be surprising to
everyone here but is surprising i think
too many Americans is that there are no
federal regulations on expiration dates
so those dates you see on food best buy
used by salebuy there there are no
federal laws that limit what that
languages that require to be set in a
certain way they're just completely
really up to companies to set those and
in fact the food and drug administration
has chosen not to regulate because
they've said this this has nothing to do
with safety and so and we're really in
the business of regulating around safety
and things that are misleading but this
doesn't really arise to something we're
concerned about so the interesting legal
research came when we looked at states
and you can see here and also on this
map and we mapped out what states then
regulate and what we found was that
forty percent aside 41 states require
date labels on at least one food product
and if you can see I know you can't see
all the little icons but at the bottom
you can see how many different food
options there were four what states
regulated so here in Massachusetts we
regulate the most we require date labels
on a wide variety of foods some states
require them just on SE milkar seafood
and then states like New York and not an
eight other states don't require dates
on anything and then this map then shows
which states restrict sale or donation
of food after that day and that's about
20 states and so again on these days
that are not related to safety and are
not regulated people won't only allow
you to sell or donate them afterwards
and so this I'm not going to go through
so much detail but this leads to
significant waste we don't know
great data which is really one of our
primary recommendations that at the US
like other countries that are concerned
about this should be monitoring and
following data on this topic we have
data from businesses in 2001 nine
hundred million dollars of food was
thrown away before it was sold because
of dates expiring you know fifteen years
later that has to be way more than that
and then the as I said this this date is
not linked to safety and in fact there's
not been a single instance of foodborne
illness linked to eating food after the
date yet ninety percent of consumers
have said that they've thrown food away
on that date because they're afraid it's
unsafe and many people also will eat
food up until the date no matter what
happened to it because they're fearful
that they believe that the food is
protected like that data is a special
halo that makes it safe until then so
this isn't contributing to safety and so
as a clinic our role is really to get
involved we're now working on
implementing these we're working on
federal legislation and relatedly we're
working on some other policy issues
particularly tax incentive and liability
so thank you very much